wow those lights are bright hold on all
right
now thumbnail john crease bane stance
all right so cobra kai season two i know
i was gonna do a video on cobra kai
season two and season three came out but
there's no
real foreseeable release date for season
three plus cobra kai just came to
netflix
recently-ish some weeks ago point is
i watched it all from episode one of
season one through season two it just
gets better and better every time i
watch it also spoilers because i have to
talk about the end
of this season i have to because it's a
big part of the impact it leaves you
with
in fact it's it's all that so spoiler
alert watch cobra kai season 2 before
you watch this you just should
and cobra kind of season 2 it does what
a sequel should do is it just
it steps it up it raises the stakes
without losing
what it was that made it enjoyable to
begin with season one ended miguel wins
the tournament and john crease
shows up which total mandela effect i
thought martin cove had died
i don't know why i just and so in the
show and he was like oh he's dead i'm
like yeah
they wrote him out of the universe
because there he is he was a great
addition to season two he shows up right
when johnny's like okay we got to go
back to the drawing board a bit
because miguel was fighting dirty and i
don't want to be that karate teacher
that tells my student to sweep the leg
or i don't want my students to at least
believe
that that's how they should fight it
just shows that johnny does want to do
right by his students he wants to be a
good teacher then enter the devil who
kind of gets the ear of some of the
students and
things start going bad for johnny but
you do see why
johnny wants to you know he wants to
give this guy a second chance though
i would argue if you're dealing with
that guy he had
second third and fourth chances well one
of the things i always liked about cobra
kai is it
showed perspective you know it's really
good at showing you the perspective of
the other side
in cobra kai seasons one and two daniel
comes across
as a bit of a smarmy prick he's always
passive aggressive to johnny talks down
to him they're at that restaurant johnny
orders the coors
he's like what daniel's like nothing
johnny enjoy your course
i'm like wooly wood before you said that
dick and you look back at karate kid and
you're like
yeah he kind of was then too i mean i
know we're supposed to root for him
but really going back and watching
karate
kid after cobra kai you see it with
different lenses i now see daniel as
this kid with a short fuse who's pretty
quick to get into fights
that might have been on the path to be
an [ __ ]
but mr miyagi found him and put him on a
good path it actually makes the karate
kid mythos a bit deeper and those are
the layers to karate kid that cobra kai
the series is retroactively peeling back
and exposing and you see that with hawk
hawk has become
full-blown bully mode when you look back
to where hawk came from you see a bit of
a flashback with hawk in season two
you're like
it's this is how bullies are made but
john crease isn't the only addition to
season two
stingray paul walter houser he's
he's so ridiculous i just find the guy
so funny he's funny and endear
he's a perfect fit for cobra kai is he
too old to be in that dojo
absolutely but they joke around with
that but in gushing about what i like
about kobra kai what works for me
the point is it just has a remarkable
amount of heart
the whole thing's about redemption the
whole thing is about johnny trying to
be the best version of cobra kai
possible whether it be the start of a
romance with miguel's mom and johnny
whether
it be really the father-son relationship
with johnny and miguel
all stemming from the fact that he was
an absentee father and he feels that he
knows his mistakes he recognizes that he
wasn't there for his son
and if his son would have him now he
would be a father to his son but
his son's just resentful so when this
father-son relationship between him and
his student miguel he sees the
opportunity to be the father he never
had and the father he never was
there's something nice about that you
know it's like it makes you you just
root for johnny but for me a
surprisingly
enjoyable and surprisingly heartfelt
part of this entire season in season two
was when he caught up with his old cobra
kai buddies just yeah it's like all
right johnny's on this path but how are
they
like one's a pastor now they've all
moved past cobra kai but
then they start talking about how john
crease messed them up and they took
those lessons into their adult lives and
when you've learned that rob garrison
the guy from
karate kid you know the johnny kid of a
party bad guy that guy he dies in the
show
but he also died in real life it makes
it sad it makes it a real good buy i was
just kind of crushed to hear that point
is cobra kai's season two would
wherever it had to step it up you know
do that next chapter
make the stakes higher but don't lose
who you are don't lose what made season
one great it does all that i think it
did it very well
it does still have the teen drama
absolutely i'd be kind of baffled if it
didn't because that's how teenagers in
high school are i mean you're still
dealing with teenagers in high school
and every karate kid
movie has a romantic interest so
whenever it starts to overcook it on
that angle and this girl breaks up with
this guy now she's saying this guy this
show still keeps me focused on what i
like about the show and yes the catalyst
to the big throw down at the ends was
it literally is a girl saw her boyfriend
kiss another girl fight ensues in school
just look at that information
it doesn't seem too spectacular but my
god that fight was
damn entertaining and i like the fact
that all right season one we had our
tournament season two
you have a straight up fight these kids
are out for blood man i mean
the warring dojos of cobra kai and
miyagi do dojo it's come to a head and i
suppose i just i give that
catalyst to pass because a well you're
talking about a fight in high school how
else would it go down
but two it leaves you on a very dark
note because
miguel shows mercy and then
90s heartthrob team
dude johnny's son in this show looks
like the flash went
back in time snatched up some 90s
heartthrob from 1995
ran through the speed force dropped him
off in 2018 and was like here you go
cobra kai have fun the point is miguel
gets knocked over
a rail falls down a flight of stairs
smacks his back
he's in bad shape and the fact that it
leaves you on that note i think is
so good because it just gives you time
to soak it all in i'm left thinking
about johnny's left
playing that really somber rendition of
curl summer it's a great version i may
or may not have listened to it
quite a few times which cruel summer
played in the original karate kid when
daniel was at school
i think it was his first day at school
then it plays in cobra kai season 2 the
very last episode when they go back to
school after summer
then it plays this version of cruel
summer when johnny's just reflecting
on his failures you really feel like
johnny wanted to redeem his past with
the present you know he wanted to do
right by his students he wanted to do
right by miguel and he was so close to
it i saw a little bit of
fan anger the fact that johnny and
daniel never had their fight but i
always felt like they had their fight
they had their fight in the tournament
yeah there's new beef sprouting but it's
not really with
johnny it really daniel should fight
john crease he should fight him i was
more interested in the fact that they
sat down at dinner and they started to
break bread they
shook hands and it's always that close
enough thing ever they were so close
this season with flashbacks and
execution builds up what cobra kai means
to johnny and you really feel the fact
that this guy
wanted cobra kai as it should have been
you know remembered lord of the rings
when gandalf comes back gandalf the
white and he was like i am sorry man
i'm sorry man as he should have been
that's johnny and cobra kai johnny's
like this is cobra kai but it's cobra
kai as it should have been then john
crease comes in and makes it kobrakai as
it always was
then miguel johnny's surrogate sun
figure gets possibly paralyzed miguel's
mom wants nothing to do with johnny
after this i don't want to see him
anymore cherry on top at least he can go
back to the drawing board nope he lost
cobra kite to john crease and that's
just what he's left with he walks away
which weirdly
i find that to be like that's a good
ending to the story
i don't know what season three is going
to bring us but if this was the end i'd
be fine with it being an ending
not that i want the show to end i want
it to go on if they can keep this
up but i find it to be a good ending in
the sense that
i don't know if you agree let me know
but i find it to be a good ending in the
way that i find
avengers infinity war to be a better
ending than avengers end game i mean
just think of that tony stark becomes
iron man because he wants to protect the
people he put in harm's way his company
sold
weapons to terrorists and then it builds
and then there are more avengers and
they have to stop the threat of loki and
then it builds and there are more
avengers
and then they have to stop ultron which
tony stark also created
and then it builds and thanos is coming
and thanos is like nope
happy you get vaporized evil wins the
end that'll teach you to be good
because good is dumb it's just something
really dark and messed up
but i don't know it's a good ending it's
not a fulfilling ending
but it's just one of the maybe i'm in a
dark place maybe 20 20 did that to me
and when failure happens in cobra kai
when
action and consequence happens when the
youth in the show
make a decision that leads to bad things
you feel the gravity of that failure and
more importantly
you feel the gravity of that failure on
the shoulders of the previous generation
and more importantly
than that you feel that those characters
feel it it's not just enough that you
feel it you gotta know that they feel it
and they really do like after miguel's
in the hospital after he i don't know
will he walk again no one knows daniel
and johnny are in that elevator and you
expect that
daniel's probably thinking like oh you
did this johnny it's your fault but in
the end
you know that they both feel like they
both failed their students and that's a
very important thing and that's a thing
that cobra kai does
so well is it's a story of
johnny and daniel it's the story of the
previous generation
while also having a new generation of
students and making it their story as
well
and when the new generation does
something that leads to bad things or
leads to very dire consequences it's not
just on
the youth it's not just on the students
it's not just on the new generation
it's on the old generation too it's both
of their stories
making one continuous story and it's
weird to me that cobra kai
does that better than
certain other properties that take place
in this galaxy or in a galaxy far far
away
and that's why when cobra kai steps into
the hole like oh this is teen drama
going down
it doesn't just feel like isolated teen
drama it
leads to an outcome that then reflects
on the teachers and that's where we
leave them johnny sits tears in
eyes staring into the sunset drink in
hand realizing that some people get to
be the
smarmy used car salesman guru of the
valley while others get punished for
daring to crawl out of the hole they dug
that they call their lives
punished for daring to try to get out of
the shadow of the sins of their past the
kid he saw as a son might never walk
again and lose the love interest
loses his business to the devil loses
the heart and the respect of the
students
all because he dared to try
and that's where we leave off with
johnny i don't know what the future of
cobra kai is i don't know what season
three is gonna have
i i've kept my ear out of all the rumors
i heard
maybe it'll take place in japan but for
cobra kai seasons one and two i think
it's an enjoyable watch it's a fun watch
it's a light-hearted watch
it's a funny watch but also has heart
and by the end there's something big
about seeing somebody just carry these
burdens
if you just step back and think about
that johnny's sitting on a beach
reflecting on the fact that if he had
never entered miguel's life
miguel's life would be better his intent
aside
that's what's going through his mind and
that's just that's a shitty feeling
the empire strikes back of the karate
kid series all right so cobra kai season
two have you seen it why did you think
about it how does it compare to season
one do you like one better than two two
better than one whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you